yeah but do you want to win or do you
just want to win underway though like
what competition these are my options
okay I could say it nicely they're still
gonna do the same thing or I have to
live with their delusion I have to use
their language I have to I have to have
them in my bathrooms and I have to play
with them is it really delusional to
call them trans women is this still not
CIS women I would say if we're having
them if we're pretending that there's
something that they're not which I I
would say it is women I would say I
would say I would say a trans a dude
that transitioned to a woman sorry I
would say even though they got the
surgery even though they're dressing
like it they're still not women
when you put them in our bathrooms it's
like now I have to pretend and act like
it's normal